hey guys i'm just mcdonald it would be
eleventh of june today and you're
watching games but news we're about
halfway through the e3 festivities and
here's the biggest and best of what you
probably want to know first up we got
word that pac-man is getting ready to
Nam his way through the inhabitants of
super smash brothers although to be fair
is doing quite a bit more punching the
numbing Nintendo revealed the news at a
special super smash brothers event and
apparently the little yellow spheres
inclusion was intended from the outset
some of his attacks include eating dots
and throwing worked as well as
transforming into a pizza type character
to bring the pain the newly released
trailer also features mr. game & watch
so it might not be too far-fetched to
assume he'll make his way back to the
series and now for some revolutionary
info Bungie have said that they're
hoping to get destiny to 1080p and 30
frames per second on Xbox one the damn
told geoff keighley of james trailers at
the boost in graphical power is possible
thanks to the june xbox one sdk for
developers which microsoft said improves
the consoles GPU power we don't have any
word just yet on what resolution the
game will be on ps4 let me know if you
think this marks a turning point for the
Xbox one's ability to deliver better
graphics Ubisoft have landed themselves
in quite a bit of hot water since even
though Assassin's Creed unity looks
really good some gamers are a tad miffed
about the lack of any playable female
characters the publisher explained that
their work would have doubled if they'd
chosen to include lady assassins you'd
be technical director James serene said
it was on their future list but the work
load requirements including animation
reworking and costume creation resulted
in the decision to scrap it the story
doesn't stop there though because just a
little while ago Jonathan Cooper and X
Ubisoft dev who now works at Naughty Dog
that it would not have been as difficult
as the publisher seemed to suggest
specifically Cooper said in my educated
opinion i would estimate this to be a
day or choose work not a replacement of
8,000 animations man if i had a dollar
every time someone at ubisoft tried to
[ __ ] me on animation tech did your
the point home by mentioning that the
female protagonist of AC liberation
shares more of comic kenway's animations
from AC 3 then AC fourth Edward Kenway
does if this is just a skin issue than
that may explain some of the uproar
although we aren't sure just yet if the
male character choice is somehow
involved in how the story is being
unraveled the last thing I wanted to
tell you about is that uncharted 4 got a
bunch of story details an interview with
the game's devs Neil druckmann and Bruce
Stanley also from the last of us
delivered a bunch of info on the crazy
anticipated title an official synopsis
indicated that nathan drake is going to
be forced back into the world of thieves
embarking on a globe-trotting journey
chasing a pirate treasure mostly we've
just been promised that everything is
going to get bigger and better but we've
been told that neat score moveset will
be changed up together with his ways of
engaging in combat and traversing the
game world they're also promising
Nathan's greatest adventure yet as you'd
hope let me know down in that commenting
section if you're keen for uncharted 4
and what you want to see out of the
title what we keeping you updated with
all the latest and greatest of this
year's e3 so be sure to keep it in two
games but